hi guys my name's Ross and today I'm
gonna give you a tour some time series
methods I sometimes have a tendency to
speak quite fast so if I'm speaking fast
just tell me don't be shy to say slow
down so what am I going to talk about so
this is the outline I change this a bit
on the plane but I'm gonna focus me on
state-space models and I'll show some a
new type of model that you may not have
come across which has the potential to
be quite useful so about me I'm
currently a financial engineer at Pima
which is a new financial advisory
startup based in London I previously
worked as a quant looking at sports
prediction markets and I also worked as
an economist my backgrounds in
econometrics and stats and in terms of
languages I used to work a lot in R and
now I'm increasingly Python I can say
from the like a personal development
point of view it's been really useful
because I'm like a research-based thing
and pythons made me think more about
like the quality of code and software
not quite there yet but you know it's
been very very helpful to me so and just
a quick word about my company very quick
so yeah we're a financial advisory firm
and what we try and do is that we try
and combine traditional advice with like
a strong quantitative foundation in
stats and machine learning so doing
quite a lot cool stuff but what kind of
aimed at institutional investors but we
are looking to have like a free website
which allows you to build portfolios and
stuff for you know for the general
public soon so stay tuned for that
and about pi flux so this is just a
personal project I've been working on
I'm not gonna ride a lot like selfish
reasons just I wanted like more
experience like working with software in
terms of what it like can give you
there's there's some new models one of
which I'm a comic today score driven
models and another motor type
non-gaussian States based models which
are quite useful it's also quite
original in the sense that a lot of time
series like packages and libraries right
now they kind of force you to use one
method of inference like maximum
likelihood or you know well might be a
Bayesian approach or something because
I've tried at least it'll allow you to
do both from Western models having said
this like to be honest like most these
methods it probably belong somewhere
else in the pie data stack like probably
like the stats models or something the
only reason why I haven't quite got to
the stage of maybe trying to like
integrate and it starts models is that
stats models betrays itself as like
frequent tests or like so it does things
i maximum likely heard and moment things
and i kind of like to have maintained of
like
so I'm quite wiped out what fits yeah
well I'm open to suggestions where you
guys think these methods should go
so introduction so this is kind of
obvious I guess but there are unique
characteristics you should be aware of
so time series is sequential you come on
like shuffle the deck so to speak data
and we're also interested in these late
independent structures so trends
seasonality cycles and in particular
we're interesting dynamic behavior which
could be abrupt so regime ships which is
quite pop and finance or gradual or so
you might have like behavior that just
changed every time gradually but overall
I guess you could characterize what
we're doing we're trying to forecast
future values in this series and the
uncertainty associated with it now two
approaches so this actually is a maybe a
bit deceptive because there's some
overlap but I guess it's permeates a lot
of perhaps the talks are gonna see it
this this thing as well so the
algorithmic approach focuses on try and
get like a read tight like black box and
the linear function so you're talking
about things like SPMS and your networks
random forests that kind of stuff
whereas the probabilistic approach has
been more academic but it's kind of
you're looking at this joint
distribution here so YT is your data and
ZT some latent variables and I'm gonna
focus on the one on the right today but
it's worth you know like being aware of
you over that for example newer networks
which old rage these days something like
drop out for example that actually has
like a probabilistic interpretation what
you're doing when you're doing so like
drop out if you're actually doing
approximate integration so you're
basically doing something like
approximating a Bayesian model so I
think it's really interesting to look at
that those kind of overlaps if you
haven't had chance to yet so that's just
focus boxes loops so this is something I
saw in a paper by David blight a few
years going quite like it and I thought
more recently in a package called Edward
you might have heard of it's by Justin
Tran and he's advocated this box his Lib
thing and I quite like you and I think
it's quite good time series it's not
like it's not like a true thing you
can't really like validate this is like
the best way to approach something but I
think it's so useful like Sarah sticks
so more interested in doing we build a
time series model we perform some kind
of inference so maximal likelihoods
maybe MCMC variational inference we look
to validate our model so in time series
that's a lot focus and say you're out of
sample performance like means quite
errors and stuff or maybe just looking
at
and then once you've seen that you have
an idea the weaknesses of your model and
you go back and revise and when you're
happy you can go ahead and forecast
so box Jenkins I'm going to cover this
very briefly because it was a great into
tour yesterday so I'm assuming the guys
in the room at least all experts on
Aaron than one of us but I just like
focus on the high-level idea behind this
so this is the currency of this
philosophy the Aral model so what you're
trying to do here is essentially capture
autocorrelation your series just by
these lags so you can see these two some
terms
so auto aggressive and moving average
lags so the key principles it's linear
so you can see the additive activity and
as Gaussian so this error term here is
Gaussian so the idea is that you
basically difference this series to try
and get a stationary series and then you
try and choose the lag order and then
you go ahead and forecast I don't go
into detail this but others perhaps like
maybe just like last one myth that
sometimes so this is some data sunspot
data to a common time series thing
because you can see it's very cyclical
and this is to promote so a lot of
people I've seen unlike blogs and stuff
I don't know why but like some say like
karma is a frequentist but I guess one
point I'd like to get across this is
very general is it's like models in my
opinion at least aren't frequentist or
Bayesian like the model gives you a
likelihood you can augment a likelihood
of reprise and do Bayesian inference in
it so calling a model Bayesian or
frequent is's in my opinion doesn't
really make sense so just for the hell
of it here's a are my 9 what also 9
aught aggressive lags and I was doing
metropolis Hastings so there's a
constant which is a set of quite large
variance parameter there so it's weakly
informative and the AR terms I'm just
assuming this this norwood prior and
they're basically set the variance here
so it kind of discourages terms which
are like above 1 in absolute value
because i spend to be associated more
like on stationary series not
necessarily but assess this an example
using their plots libraries you can see
this like
carries through to other models to be
nice to be doing aramis you know we're
going to want to use this library
probably but the point is that likely
the model fit here you can choose
whatever you want so here's my
metropolis Hastings I've just done like
a long chain and then I've just plotted
the model fit and yeah it's just fairly
good fit within sample and you can also
plot the latent variables so
a lot of statistical packages give you
like tables and I quite likely have to
do your graphing stuff cuz it makes
people think about uncertainty so this
is for metropolis Hastings you can see
it's a bit Wiggly because our
approximation you can see where the
uncertainty is in these AR parameters
and Z is just a term for latent
variables or parameters and forecasting
you know it looks very nice on support
data it's very easy here as well well
the limitations so these plates and
models can take you a long way and if
you're like first approaching a time
series perhaps you're going to do this
kind of thing but to be honest there's I
don't really like it from a theoretical
perspective because there's no
decomposition of the latent processes
from their data that's a bit wordy but
what I mean by that is we have some kind
of idea that we're going to fit a series
with like AR and ma lags but we're not
really directly like capturing things
like trends cycles ideally what we'd
like to do is actually get them directly
out the model by specifying a model so
it has these components and then we
extract it run this fitting lags and
like assuming that were capturing these
features a more general more generally
many problems will care about non
Gaussian and nonlinear so we need a more
intuitive and theoretically complete
framework and this is what's called
structural time series so this I'm going
to explain it intuitively so what's
going on here
why imagine this is like a univariate
time series why we see Y is a function
of some unknown States so to give an
example imagine we have some tracking in
a tracking data on someone but imagine
it's tracking data as a bit [ __ ] so like
in that situation we'd be interested in
the state would be that we don't
directly observe where is the actual
position of this person and when it
can't get measurements in and we want to
filter out the signal from the noise and
that's the basic principle behind the
state space model so we observe some
time series why the series evolved
according to some latent States and we
want to capture this signal and its
noise so that's the the state equation
there the Alpha and so it's like a
Markov form and that's the underlying
thing we really want to get out of this
and Y is a function of this unknown
thing plus some measurement error so
that kind of makes sense
a good anticipation we're going to come
onto that but before we do let's let's
think about the problems that this
solves and again this is a bit widely
but there are three things filtering is
that you're interested in the current
state given like current and previous
measurements you're interested in the
present a lot of times for like big data
you're interested with filtering because
you don't have to store in all the data
in the past that's a bit costly
prediction is similar but you're
interested in future states and
smoothing is that you're interested in
the past so you if you want to notice
what the true location of some one was
ten minutes ago or something you can use
future and past data and this is going
to come on to the camera filter CSE as
you said so actually there's a for the
formalist I showed you just two slides
ago there's a closed-form solution for
this linear and gaussian case and it's
celebrated Kalman filter and smoother so
the Kalman filter was actually due up in
the fifties and sixties its first use
was actually all major useful in the
Apollo missions and what they were
interested in is basically trying to get
the land on the moon without you know
crashing or bouncing off and they had
like noisy measurements the history's up
to quite interesting because they
actually consider using an algorithm
called weighted least squares but that
was too computationally intensive or the
computers they were using at the time so
they ended up using a Kalman filter
because it's a filter and they don't
restore the past data so it's quite
interesting but unfortunate I get I I
work on planets so I don't get to do
like useful stuff like not the other
moon however useful that may be so hilar
winter tuitions so alpha again is the
state right and you don't to worry about
the Barretts term P but I suppose your
idea of uncertainty and so what's your
function of so this term here the YT
minus CT alpha I see a prediction error
so imagine that you under predict right
then you're going to want to go into
this equation you want to up your state
prediction to try and get closer
given the new information you have so
you're basically responding in the
direction of this prediction error and
the Kalman gain term here is Katie and
that's me we're basically determine how
much you reacted to this like error so
it's a bit like a learning rate if you
come from like a company like background
like it's basically your reaction to
this information and what we actually
estimating this model is like high
parameters which determine is strength
of reaction so here's a classic example
so discharge from the River Nile so what
does this mean this is just the water
that comes out the Delta or
niall and so this is a good thing to
apply simple state state space model to
so let's imagine we want to know how
this how the level of water coming out
from the nail has changed over time so
the simplest type of structural model is
a local level model so what's going on
here we have a univariate series and we
have it as a function of a time varying
mean which is this mutant and we assume
the mute erm is a function of a random
walk that's capturing the variation of
our time we haven't come across random
walks before this thing's like a drunk
guy in a desert like he's not gonna
really stay to one location he's just
gonna kind of like wander around so like
and the important thing is for the
linear case we have a closed form
solution for this for the Kalman filter
I'm going to estimate these like
variance parameters which again is just
the signal-to-noise ratio if you like
how much will react and so this is the
smooth estimate and it's very nice so we
see that in the late 19th century that's
a long time ago the mean is going down
to a lower level and you can see it's
smooth so that's why it's nice and
smooth because we're using the future
data as well just to do do analysis here
so that's the level because it's varied
over time and that's the measurement
noise at the bottom there so this is why
I actually fell they build a dam it's so
slight kind of obvious right but it's
nice that simple more look like this can
capture something like that and this
I'm not going to capture go into detail
on this type of model but this is stress
is the signal extraction point so rather
than say with an arrow model what we do
to remove a trend is we might like fit
like a linear trend or something in this
type of model we have again a local
level but we assume the trend like
varies every time so this is for US GDP
so it's tends to go up and what we can
capture in the bottom left here is just
the underlying growth rate so is because
it gives idea of the underlying growth
strength the US economy so for example
after 2008 we're kind of in a like low I
say we and I'm from UK I'm not going to
about wrecks it that's a whole load of
bloody problems but the regime here is
like yeah you can see it's like a low
regime than it was in the past but as
I've said before TTP's actually a pretty
bad measure but let's not go into that
but you can see the principle right
we've extracting the trend and it's
instead of just like capturing it free
some lags we have a really intuitive
things so you could show this to someone
say look this
where we think the trend is and it's
lower its very intelligible what's that
oh yeah the graphs are done using a
seaborne so it's kind of like yeah
extension to my portal yeah so dynamic
regression models so now we're getting a
bit a bit further on but imagine we just
have like a simple problem like a linear
regression or something but we think
that the coefficients vary over time
that's perfectly reasonable thing we
could expect to happen for a lot of data
so now it's the coefficients which are
following random walks and we're going
to model this so this is simple and
powerful for dynamic relationships and
here's a finite example so in finance
were often interested in is trying to
find a systematic risk so for example if
you imagine a stock we want to know how
much of the variation is due to the
market and in this case we want to know
how much is like you know how does it
vary over time that's a systemic risk so
here's an example here so I just set up
a don't have a regression model and I've
specified what I want to regression like
using Patsey notation so Amazon on the
S&P market and like here's this move
estimate so you could see example in
2014 quite a lot of Hispanic risk it
seems and it drops down close to about 1
in terms of the intuition if it's above
1 minutes reacting heavily with the
market like more than the market it's
below 1 it's not really that correlated
with the market there's a problem here
so I'm showing you a smooth festival now
if we imagine actually like using like
beaches and like finance and we're
probably gonna be interest more in the
filter thing like what do we think now
and the filter thing has some problems
so do you see in like 2015 these massive
jumps down so it goes from about 1 to
almost no 25 but these are big jumps so
this is a limitation than what are we
using which the Kalman filter is only
optimal for linear and Gaussian
assumptions so the jumps in 2015 are
caused by tell events which I'll show
you on the next slide so if we're using
a filter Nessman using these assumptions
and it's not particularly useful like if
we use the beta after jump then we're
going to potentially severely
underestimate systemic risk which is not
good at all and this is showing the
components so if you look at the top
graph that we look at like 2015 you see
there's a massive spikes for Amazon
they've had like for example big spikes
and the reason why it goes down the beat
here is because
weren't corresponding spikes for the S&P
500 so these are if these were
idiosyncratic events what Amazon and
that's why you get these weird you know
jumps which aren't very desirable
limitations no I've only just scratch
the surface so state-space models couch
there are so many cool things I have
cyclical and seasonal components the
ranking models and luck of switching
models and like what we've like gained
more interpretive ability of our
immortals like there's some problems
here we want something it's non Gaussian
we've just seen something where a
Gaussian sumption you know implicitly
view like isn't really working for us
ideally is why we'd like a none Gaussian
filter like there are smoothies
available but a filter is kind of useful
for like a lot of you know practical
problems and we might also like to drop
in the arity but that's we're never
talked so school driven time today so
this is like a new type model that I
will introduce today so let's let's
revisit the Kalman filter and almost to
the hour ago so let's have a look at
this equation here so the state equation
is evolving according to a linear
prediction error and that's why you're
getting these weird events with the beta
thing you saw a few slides ago it's
reacting linearly to the tee shots and
actually if you have a massive tell
event it's going to react quite a lot
and also the armor you know example has
a similar similar thing here this
particular process you see the YT minus
mu T similar to the YT minus T alpha T
like this linear prediction error is
looking problems so one of the
motivations will score driven models
which I introduced a bit is that we
won't achieve something that's Kalman
light because the Kalman filters like
the elegant
used to looking quick but we want it to
happen you know have something like the
Kalman filter for other distributions
and one way to achieve this is through
the score of the distribution so what is
the score so you don't forget for your
the mass it's actually pretty simple we
go through it but let me just to show
the intuition here so basically if we
this thing at the top here this is the
log density for like a normal
distribution and basically we just take
derivatives and we get like something
like a Newton like update if you if you
don't come across like Newton based
methods don't worry well basically the
point is here for the normal
distribution you see this linear
prediction error comes out again that's
like the way to update the parameter for
this particular point in time
so basically the idea is given that the
score distribution which they
derivatives is can win like why we
exploit this principle further
distributions so again for example we
can look at present distribution and
again we take derivatives and we get
like an update term which we can use
which is like a bit like a Kalman filter
so this is the basic idea we want an
approximate filter for other
distributions and so that's a good
question so exponential family models it
tends to work best with them but you can
use other things which other than the
exponential family but you're right once
you get like you know things which
highlight differentiable and things like
that all the different the second
derivatives are like they're messy it
kind of loses its appeal a bit but you
can technically yes still do it for not
an exponential family models the school
specifically so on this guy here for
example the score is just going to be
the gradient in terms when these models
we can actually scale it if we like by
the Hessian based term as well to get
something which is a bit more it takes
into account the curvature so it's a bit
like a Taylor approximation but a school
specifically is just going to be the
derivative so you could have like a
simple score based water which just uses
the gradient and it represents something
up there like you know stochastic rate
of descent in the way so you can basic
use any degree of you know complexity
with those derivatives so again don't go
through this but basically the price on
saying we have something here and we
base have a scaling term here so that
gives us like in a you know approximate
filter for the price on distribution so
we have an error term exponential of PT
here is basically where you think that
the press'll rate is going to be and we
have a scaling term here exponential
we'd have to worry about I'm saying this
fully yeah the point is we can you know
take derivatives can get something
approximate so let me give an example so
my dad said a family are from Nottingham
which is a town in England and stay all
spawn not in forest and they've a
complete reverse side I don't really
want to mention they'll promote the name
of a called Derby FC and they can they
have a rivalry and they've gone back
like basically since 1896 so I've just
got some data here when it's in the
scores for these two teams
and you can see it's this is what count
data tends to look like so it's quite
hard to identify like
trends and things like just eyeballing
this stuff but this is
calendar so I showed you like the de
River example for like dowsing like a
level model let's do a price on local
level model just using the school so
what I'm going to do here is I've got a
price on assumption for each team's
goals and I assume the rate is gonna be
a function of a local level so we
assuming that B you know perhaps the
goal scoring rate of each team varies
over time and also a time varying home
advantage effect which because home
advantage tends to be a big thing in
sports and here's an example so I've set
up a gas progression and I've progressed
forests not in forests goals and say a
home advantage parameter plugged in the
data and I've chosen the family I want
so I've used a price on assumption and
you can see the variation every time you
can do the same thing but Derby and then
what I've done is basically if you
combine these these two results you can
get a very crude relative dominance with
it measure over time and so you can see
I've actually that's not games play
that's the year and I'm gonna talk about
in a bit if they're above 0 then based
on these head-to-head results we think
foresters superior we think below 0 then
we think Darbar superior but this is
very crude we've assumed equally spaced
intervals print games which you see
these you can't see on this screen but
you know just you know a small think of
World War 1 World War two which stopped
football unfortunately awesome soccer
sorry and also its head-to-head games so
it's only the games between these two
teams that's not a great source you want
to see you know how good these teams
actually are but you know that's that's
a good start and that these types of
models they fit into like a more general
class there's gas regression models so
again it's like the dynamic progression
model as I said before but now we're
using a score term rather than like a
common term to update these coefficients
but it's basically something like a
random walk again right if the beat
hoods a function itself plus the score
driven term so let's go back to that
bonus example again don't worry about
trying to understand every detail of the
term but the score for T distribution
has a nice properties basically the T
distribution has a degrees of freedom
parameter is really large
it's just the T dispersion is this
Gaussian but if it's low then what you
see with this disk or distribution as
I'll show in the next slide so actually
it's very nice because it trims out
so gives you robustness and this this
graph is is quite useful in a suspect so
what we have here on the x-axis is the
prediction error error and on the other
term we have like the reaction from the
score so if we have the blue line you
can't really see the legend apologies
for that but if you take the blue line
here that's a has a very large degrees
of freedom so it specially normal so
that's that linear almost always a
little linear pattern and that's why
it's not very robust outliers so if you
take like a really negative thing it's
gonna react quite heavily whereas the
green one has a low degrees of freedom
parameter and as you can see it's it's
more robust right
so if you have a hybrid dictionnaire
it's going to react less and that's the
kind of thing we like for Finance now
she has a weirder property which is as
you go to like infinity for the
prediction error it doesn't react at all
which is a bit weird but yeah
interesting still and I'm going to go
straight to the next page but basically
he can get the the beat route and here's
a comparison so in green we have the
Kalman filter which has you know these
jumps and in blue we've got our robust
filter which is doing a much better job
as you can see it's not reacting as
heavily to their tails it's not perfect
for example this guy here is a bit bit
heavy but it's far more robust so you
know we've much every wants to use this
this and like oh I know portfolio
analysis we'd much preferred like the
blue one and the green one so that's an
attraction of that kind of model it's a
summary these get us to the these types
of models gassed and non Gaussian world
but we have some limitations there is no
simple way to obtain smooth estimates in
this setting you can a kind of fudge it
a bit but it hasn't really worked out
yeah a bigger problem is like okay so
we're getting something like the Kalman
filter very nice but what does it
actually approximate so okay it looks
something like a like the state space
model but not quite so I think that's
problematic like ideally when you're
doing approximation techniques you want
something theoretical which tells you
the degree approximation so you might
come across things like KL divergence
and things like that which is a direct
metric and gives you a lower bound in
the approximation there is something
like that these models but it's not
quite worked out and I think that's both
problematic to be honest and then
non-linearity so we all care about
non-linearity these days so I mean you
could have an alternative model tight
but there's there's good ways perhaps to
try and get non-linearity within this
class
models so just exploiting things like
Colonel trick which is very useful also
just by paying in Gaussian process based
terms as well
look at those up even you haven't hoped
against them they're quite interesting
okay so let's do something fun
well finance is fun right come on we
have some precedents in the literature
so a lot of people actually models model
sports it's now very popular of like
sports analytics and you can even see
like what also like 538 and stuff for
sports what I'm interested in here is
kind of like looking in this state space
framework at the top too and also a guy
here so the top two ones for NFL wants
soccer and what that basically
interested in is trying to model
abilities of teams over time how they
change over time and the third one here
is also interesting hierarchical models
are very popular because if you don't
have a lot of data in sports and you
just use something like maximum
likelihood then you're going to
dramatically overestimate or
underestimate ability it tends to be a
bit rough so what hierarchical models do
is they basically pull information so
you can check those out as well but I'm
going to focus on state-space models
this framework there are actually more
powerful approaches these days I can't
really touch upon that that much but
we'll take the same basic approaches
this is a great way to start thinking
about these problems and it's still
insightful and fun so we're gonna use a
glim based framework so we're going to
talk in terms of these like probability
distribution if we talked about it like
price or normal etcetera we'll have time
varying abilities and we're gonna focus
on teams I mean a power effect on the
game outcome what a power effect means
is basically the team enters like a
formula like a formula for say you know
points or goals basically as I like a
coefficient search example of it's a
soccer game and it's like Leicester
versus whole we have a coefficient for
these different teams that comes if they
happen to be in that in that match so it
pops up and they have a power effect
example if they have high power then
you're gonna get lots of goals or low
power you know the opposite so data I've
just taken some basic data so about
3,000 NFL games from 2006 2016 we have
information in the home scores away
schools teams and quarterbacks and we
have regular season and postseason games
not using preseason games if you think
about why I'm not
and we'll focus on modeling the point
difference so this what the point
difference looks like so a lot of people
just look at this and say okay well it's
not quite normal but we could do
something like that and that might be an
okay assumption so if you've read like
you know gell-mann's Birkin patient data
analysis stays a normal assumption the
Lichtman the guy I mentioned two slides
ago they use a normal assumption so you
can use more complex things like widget
have a skewness and stuff but let's just
let's just go for a normal distribution
we assume it's normally distributed and
this is the one that we're gonna go for
so we assumed the point difference we're
gonna model it by this location
parameter Mew we assumed as a function
of a home advantage effect and these
power terms
so imagine time T this is a match or
something I think the indexing is a bit
wrong here but whatever so we have a
home team alpha T I and the way Team
Alpha T J and the power is going to
affect where we think the expected
points are these teams that make sense
and we're gonna model these team
abilities as a random walk processes but
we're using the bagasse term here and
there's gonna be the normal distribution
to try and drive these dynamic updates
so you can see I and J again
home-and-away teams and again they're
following random walks the signs
negative here cuz one of the teams is
the away team and they also gonna have a
different sign effect and the point
difference so I've just included this
recently just for fun so you basically
define the data define the the columns
which are specifying the home team in a
waste team strings define what's the
point difference of school difference
so here NFL it's like a points death it
could be something like goals dip if
you're doing sock or something and then
define the family you're making the
assumption about so we assumed a normal
here and we're doing like sports like
soccer for this very basic model we
might want to do some like scaling which
is just like a distribution the
difference between two price homes or
something basically the point when I get
is there's different assumptions you can
make here so here's here's some output
so I don't know what teams you guys
support I've got some graphs here you
can see the games they played in 2006
and how they've evolved over time so we
have here the Patriots who are like you
know basically at dynasty for the past
10 years
through you know legitimate or
illegitimate means I don't know sorry
and with a team like the Panthers who
have become very prominent recent years
and you'll excuse me up Denver Broncos
they've they've gone up recently and we
have Green Bay Packers who are kind of
goodish but never quite got it recently
California franchises they used to be
good basically but zero by the way means
about average so they're actually these
three teams now below average San
Francisco were good for a while in 2013
they've gone down a bit now Oakland
Raiders have been a bit bad generally
getting better and their charges as well
it's a bit of a bleep pitch now so I'm
sorry about that
okay let's extend that so and it feels a
bit weird in the sense that like there's
a lot reliance on one player to call it
back now there are powers in other
sports like soccer might have like a
star striker or something but the
callback is really weird cuz that base
like an abandoned you on the pitch space
range so this this I have a course by
component component so again we've got
abilities here but now we have another
component specifying the course packed
in a match so we're moving by gamma so
if it's like I'd know Denver Broncos or
some versus some team last year then
we'd have like Peyton Manning or was
white all over in that it's basically
exactly the same as team abilities now
we've got a quarterback component and
we're in a moderate as a random walk
process as well so the same model I've
just like got like just easy syntax so I
had a second component so home court
packed and away courts back
it's basically I guess a second term for
that team if you like we fit the model
and let's have a look at some for us
yes for this model when you first
specify it you actually no I don't think
you do in this particular model because
you've basically just defined a
home-and-away team just by the strings I
probably could use Patsy or something
like that so it's a good show if I used
Patsy elsewhere so Super Bowl 50 you can
see the career history here it's not
quite career history because it goes
back to 2006 and Manning was obviously
before that time so cam neo-nazis shut
up in the last last season Peyton
Manning seemed to have a resurgent but
was probably a bit on the decline good
question is well can we get uncertainty
for these kind of things like what would
the confidence bounce
you can you basically have to just know
the uncertainty of the the learning rate
term but anyway the point is those days
to be quarterbacks you can also do
things like fun so look at know one
quarterback draft picks so the top there
is like peyton manning again alex smith
is also particularly like this model
he's the light blue up there carson
palmer is in the purple he said of
resurgence Ellie Manning has been ok-ish
we've averaged Michael Vick I know the
guys and this going to get into the kind
of limitation so this might a lot better
I mean Tom Brady's obvious like an
amazing quarterback so that that's fine
and Russell Wilson as well but someone
like Aaron Rodgers so basically I need
to support position for a bet and we
always have these examples of players
that aren't quite picked up by basic
models in soccer the examples like Meza
Ursel who's like a play for Arsenal so
incredible player we don't quite pick up
his contribution we're looking at basic
stats and Aaron Rodgers is kind of
similar and in this respect I mean it
definitely picks him up as a good
quarterback but not like you know not
say like top three or something like
that
well that's potentially wrong so let's
quickly review that all models are wrong
so we're giving credits purely on points
they were rich data sets available we
can face on punts slave-like net no
posse ARDS all this kind of stuff and
also just detailed in-game data as well
the other thing is we've decision power
ratings for the point difference but we
really want hair is like attacking and
defensive contribution as well as a lot
showing a bit and also we've just got a
quarterback component but course
I quarterback performance is heavily
dependent on things like the quality of
your wide receivers do they make a catch
and your offensive line and a more
general point if you just want to make
you know if you yourself wanna make more
complex models it's like think about the
nature of football like points are
generated from different sources
touchdowns field goals safeties I mean
there's a common component then that you
progress up the pitch so that makes you
more likely to get touchdowns and a
field goal but that's a limitation is
doing a simple model so Aaron Rodgers
sickly example had a not a good year
last year but probably wasn't his fault
he's got some amazing like moments like
Hail Marys and stuff but his offensive
line wasn't that great and then Jordy
Nelson it was their star wide receiver
got put out so this model doesn't take
that into account so it wouldn't really
like him that much but that's not
technically right and defense matters so
for finals it's like just got the
consensus point spread for the Super
Bowl last year so everyone was heavily
on the Panthers and I was got the two
models here and basically the market and
these two basic models completely wrong
like the Broncos like smashed it and
they did it because they had like a
really world class like defensive
performance and that's a limitation in
the model now what you could say is well
like the world's probabilistic maybe you
know that is the right expectation we're
just happen to go that particular way
like if someone had done some certain
thing in the matched and cuts like that
Panthers we get some momentum or
something like that but you still gotta
use your intuition a bit like you should
probably model the defense and I'm gonna
finish using box asleep so again I've
shown you some models I've mainly
focused on the modeling bear toss a bit
on the inference not much invalidation
most when to look at I hope that's given
you some good ideas yourself to like try
things out and like finance or sports or
ever and it's also just giving you like
a brief tour of the kind of models we
can use to model like time varying
behavior thank you very much
and having to take questions
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so like you can do
like more complicated stuff and like
increase the state space like there's
things like the curse of dimensionality
and stuff you should be worried about
and that links to the point about
overfitting but yeah like this dataset
you could do a lot more of it I just
showing like a very simple model yeah
yeah sorry I can't hear
okay so I basically get a similar
limitation I just looked at who was
quarterback for the majority of time
that match
so yeah down to your question or okay so
it's a lesson limitation behavior take
quarterbacks or something you make yeah
sports betting is illegal in the US and
I work and find out it's not supporting
so you have our questions or yeah
yeah let's get question so I guess
there's a number way to do that first we
could just look at classic model fit
things like the likelihood a I see SBICs
well you're probably interested in is
lye using a holdout period and then
trying to test the effect of that adding
a component so you might start with
something simple like I've done here
then gradually building components and
see what the best light level of
complexity is but you know there are
some problems of that to be honest like
you'll find often at the times if you
look at slight certain like periods in
like the history of a sport and certain
things are more predictive or not and
the nature the sport changes as well no
it's because of rule changes but other
things so like soccer for example is
like notorious for that like the style
of football just changes very rapidly
over decades so there's a serious
question about there about like what
period of data is actually valuable so
predictive power I guess you can't
reduce it to like using a holdout period
you've got to think about a bit more oh
yeah
anywhere else
okay so stationarity is say if you take
the Box Jenkins approached and you care
a lot about stationarity or you take the
state space one approach you don't
really care because it's already like
implicit within the model yes sure yeah
some men using numpy and a bear pandas
as well just to do the data formatting
I've also just pwned some like syphon in
some areas to speed up bottlenecks a bit
but yeah is this basically pure number
play there are some like limitations to
performance side that I want to address
a bit because the trouble of time series
data is that you can't really avoid for
loops in a lot of places I mean the easy
answer to say well you know put it into
siphon or something but then you also
care about in a lot of cases like having
support for like custom things the user
can put in so I show you the gas model
here you can actually put in a custom
family if you just write it the same
format
whereas if I try to move it to like a
size and base format in that particular
instance it would kind of lose the
flexibility of it so the trade-off that
I'm trying to bounce myself about what
the best approaches but it's mainly
numpy in a bits item
so the big overlap is probably with
stats models which has things like
éramos Lars and state-space models my
own focus to be honest was not these
types of models I kind of had to put
them in just as building blocks all I
wanted to do and there's my own
priorities it was these gas based models
I've also got non-gaussian models that
haven't show today and one developing
now is basically more complex models
based on Gaussian processes which are
very useful for time series but very
hard to implement deserve a great way
pretty much this need right now so it's
taking up a lot of my spare time but
it's actually being very rewarding for
me personally because like I said I'm a
research background I'm still not the
best guy in the world software
development but it's been very good for
me personally I mean if you're
interested making contributions you're
more than welcome
like I said I probably think it belongs
somewhere else like in stats models or
something but yeah I mean contribution
is very welcome yeah it seems March yeah
yeah it takes there's a lot of yeah long
nights but yeah I think I'm gonna come
down a bit now and like regain a social
life but it's been very warding I
actually recommend like well I just as a
general principle if you want to like
learn something in these types of models
I've done before but the best way to
actually really understand something is
to actually do it yourself like I can't
stress that enough it's very time
consuming and a lot of the time you'll
be under pressure to like you know just
get a result out so you'll use a
built-in library already but soon like
you do interested in your model with new
paper try playing it you know in
yourself and maybe release it as well
because it's a really good way to
understand both like how the actual
model itself works mathematically but
also to think about computational stuff
like for me like personally something
like a Gaussian process like the math
for me is easy and then where to put in
the computational sense and to worry
about things like okay it's very hard
when the matrices like using my
computers I ever think about things like
yeah how do I do those kinds of things
computationally right in that framework
also just things about like
floating-point precision over rounding
yeah like so I overflow and underflow
these kind of things like I didn't have
to worry about when I was doing research
so much I mean you did the bits you
store to use those kind of like
statistical languages but yeah seriously
did do things itself it's very rewarding
yep I think I wouldn't mean say I didn't
hear the question
oh yeah good question there's basically
no gas models available there's there's
some which are based on GARCH models in
our we said model for volatility but
there's basically no gas well I think
one of the Google summer projects is to
do it and our base package of gas models
but as far as I'm aware this is the
first mainstream gas package so when the
implication of that question is there's
still a lot of work to do and actually
try to think find out things like good
starting values deal with things like
you know simple things which you think
are simple but like large counts and
stuff like because like over routing and
stuff there's a lot to do to get us
right like is still alpha if you like
but you know better to jump in the deep
end and get something out first and
they're saying well it's pretty complex
I'm doing you have a question was by the
way if you want it yet so this is you
can do this yourself and you can I
haven't shown all the teams and stuff I
only caught it back so yeah do itself
and try over sports